when you play a witch you get to avoid a  lot of the intense tricks and choreo but  not always some of us had intense stunts  elizabeth olsen definitely had her fair  share of dangerous flying stunts we  imagine chafing was the worst of the  injuries though the few moments where  she had to exert herself she became that  character in a zombie movie the thing  out of this fight i totally totally  tripped she was trying to walk down  rubble aggressively and had to stare at  thanos rather than her feet  i  fell on my knee so hard embarrassing  she didn't just trip up in front of  thanos though yeah i think it was the  big run with all the women she fell  again despite being on wires she still  lost her balance and i lost my balance  and i fell backwards and  got totally slammed at the back of the  head ouch we watched that back multiple  times in slow motion